well the processes i think is unique to
the subject if you if you were to look
at the body of my work it moves around
from one subject to another so it could
be mining itself where we move remove
the ore from the land or it could be
tailings which is a byproduct of mining
could be quarries it could be refineries
it could be a dam in China or now could
be you know the city's being built in
China and each one of those things I
approached first as conceptually what
why why that why that not that you know
like how do I go from a general idea to
the specific place in which I'm going to
make a photograph of and there's a whole
bunch of criteria I might put to it as a
visual is it interesting you know is
there a sense of scale within it is
there is there any particular reason you
know why photograph that intersection in
LA and not another one well yes it's one
of the biggest in the world and it was
where the freeway began so there are
other components that I'll use to to
determine where my target is that I'm
going to go and try and photograph but
then once I understand like for instance
when I did the refinery series I never
tried to photograph a refinery but I
went in there with my first with a
handheld camera and just shot it just
walked through and responded gud early
to the thing I just whatever caught my
attention i'm not using 4 by 5 i'm not
slowing down I'm walking through I'm
responding then I go back and start
working with a four by five using those
kinds of touch points as a reference and
and then start to you know photograph
and then I try all kinds of films to see
how that subject and under like
conditions and words that which at
subject you know would be senator would
it be a cloudy a post partly cloudy day
you know evening or sunrise how does it
how does that subject react under the
different times a day in light what
films do the colors that the palate of
the thing I'm photographing what film
best
response to it so I'd shoot all the
different films that were available in
the market I'd make prints I'd try
different papers with it until I say AHA
here's the combination here's the film
i'm going to use this is a position to
the subject this is where in that
subject i'm going to photograph this is
the paper i'm going to use to print it
on now I've established my form of it
established my working approach and then
I'd start going back and I'd go back
maybe five six seven times in that one
first refinery then I developed the kind
of a language that I felt I was
comfortable with and then I said ok now
I'm going to try and find some other
refineries that might bring other
perspectives to it or different times
that they were built different things
that they were refining and then i would
add to that body of work until I felt
okay I've I feel I've exhausted this
I've somehow taken this visually as far
as I can go i don't have anything else
that I feel I need to say about this and
then I might close a chapter to that
project then go on to that and that
might take two or three years before I
by the time i get access into it shooted
and some things like the refineries took
three years and I was pretty much done
whereas quarries I went on and off of
cory's at different times over a period
of 17 years other projects so depends
you know how long I want to do it may be
determined by do I feel that there's
more to have be had